it's the failure of the euro threatening
to bring down the entire continent and
the rest of the world
how did it happen
[Music]
what is happening failing currencies
collapsing banks whole countries on the
edge of bankruptcy the upside versus
downside in greece is pretty attractive
a stressed investor who truly
understands great value but the
investors they fill their pockets anyway
have we lost control of the economy
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
my name is amun i have always been
fascinated by economics how it affects
society how it affects you and me
is there someone pulling the strings or
is it self-regulating based on
principles we neither understand nor
control
i have been wondering how can we take
back control
that's how i discovered
bitcoin
bitcoin is a decentralized payment
system
the first specially made internet
currency
hundreds of thousands of computers
around the world work equally in a
network to create move and record
ownership of the digital units known as
bitcoins
bitcoins are programmable digital
you can send however much you want to
whoever you want wherever you want
almost free of charge and sudo
numerously
[Music]
[Music]
um
be
[Music]
a revolution fine
but is it good or bad since 2009 the
value of the bitcoin has varied by
several million percent
the currency has been linked with
criminal networks and shady business
neither the norwegian authorities nor
others welcome this revolution
[Music]
it is
is
[Music]
you know
[Music]
foreign
despite the warnings bitcoin has gone
from obscure programming to a billion
dollar industry
many people have embraced the technology
what makes it so attractive
i've had one bitcoin and it does work
although i had a result yep
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
alternative
that's a name i'm going to hear many
times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bitcoin
[Music]
day one
forget bitcoin
cash is king
[Applause]
[Music]
fencing fault
what is needed for petrol stations and
other shops to accept bitcoin
[Music]
could the answer be found in an office
block outside copenhagen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so tell me what is coinify coinify is a
payment solution for businesses that
want to accept bitcoin payments
we have
businesses in almost every category we
have it in food in clothing in online
services electronics and so on we
provide the the bridge between the
established regulated financial world
and the new and very innovative world of
bitcoin a customer wants to buy
something in a shop with bitcoin
he can then pay the shop in bitcoin and
the shop can then forward the bitcoins
to coinify who then returns euros or
kroner to the shop's bank account and
this has a number of advantages the
business receives euros a corner they
can do bookkeeping like they're used to
it has zero fees for the business to
accept bitcoin payments in this way
and there are no
chargeback fraud like you're used to
with credit card payments
and there is a one-click payment method
so it's very easy to pay so do you feel
that the activity of coinify is
supported by the danish authorities
three years ago there was still a lot of
legal uncertainty
around bitcoin in denmark and in europe
but it has gotten better over the last
few years so today we know for sure how
to treat bitcoin legally in most areas
it can still get better but it's pretty
good
so the danish authorities are positive
what about the rest of scandinavia
finland yes
sweden
iffy norway
no
what makes it so difficult to regulate
bitcoin
the question brought me here to the
copenhagen docklands
bitcoin
[Music]
[Music]
us
can bitcoin and the financial world live
in harmony
will scandinavian countries give bitcoin
and digital currencies a chance
i think i'm ready for a beer
i can only beat that
and and with all that hey elmo for fan
come here
[Music]
so
what do you think will be the future of
of bitcoin well maybe i should talk a
bit about the past how about that
so when bitcoin came out in 2008 2009 it
looked like yet another
crazy idea
something that i'm interested in
professionally because i'm
trying to design and break code and at
the very core of bitcoin there was this
this code that i kind of knew and then i
was immediately interested in trying to
analyze it and break it
and many other of my colleagues around
the globe try to do the same
it turns out that it's still holding up
that's a good indication that it will be
something for for the long run
so what does bitcoin mean for society is
it good news sir
or bad news
you can now take control over all of
your money and you don't have to
essentially have a third party
at a bank the only way we get out of
boot of government is
to build something
where we can have a currency that works
completely aside of government control
of centralized control
um
and that's what we have today
it is certainly a dissemination of power
i think it's about a paradigm shift
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
sweden's second largest city
home to volvo
and bitcoin pioneers
[Music]
the usual suspects
the traffic department still has some
way to go
and
go standing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how many have taken the leap
how big is bitcoin really
currently there are about 100 000
bitcoin transactions per day
in comparison visa alone has 4 000
transactions per second
[Music]
can bitcoin challenge the bank's
monopoly will this system work on a
large scale
then there must be more places like feb
holland
the first big chain store to accept
bitcoin
[Music]
um
every day 200 000 bitcoins change hands
only 2.5
is used in shops
that's around 1.2 million us dollars
a drop in the ocean against the 60
billion us dollars in retail trade every
day
you have to start somewhere
[Music]
foreign
toll 36
perfect
thanks mickey
[Music]
the blockchain
a system for transactions with no
central authority
buying and selling work contracts voting
slips everything can be stored here
a system with no bureaucracy or state
control
that will be a challenge to society
maybe on a deeper level than we might
suppose
a ugandan bitcoin trader explains why
east africa is ready for bitcoin
we don't have papua we don't have other
credit cards the other countries use
when you compare using our mobile phones
transfers
it is related to bitcoin in the future
all of us will be knowing bitcoin
it's about democracy
[Music]
can bitcoin democratize society
many people think so
the swedish bitcoin party for example
we're to meet outside the parliament
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
yet
[Music]
this freedom is built into the
blockchain where all bitcoin
transactions are recorded
single transactions are collected in
blocks which the network registers every
10 minutes
[Music]
the blocks from a chain all the way back
to the first signed by nakamoto in 2009
there's something religious about it
maybe that's why i'm here in the suburbs
outside stockholm
looking for
robert
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
a democratizing technology
a shared value system a people's
currency
bitcoin must be good wasn't it
[Music]
but banks and the world of finance
they are resisting
are they scared of losing control
or are they seeing something i'm not
[Music]
80 kilometers south of the arctic circle
is it here i will find the answers
[Music]
i think i know what this old helicopter
hanger is hiding
it's here i'm hoping to find the heart
of bitcoin
welcome to can't see clear sky farm
[Music]
physically i can't get any closer to
bitcoin
in this hangar alone there are 43 000
specialized computers the real value of
bitcoin lies here
this is where the blockchain is created
what is the motivation
you better
[Music]
what is bitcoin mining so bitcoin mining
is really transaction processing
what happens is if someone wants to send
a bitcoin from person a to person b has
to be confirmed has to be guaranteed we
don't want person a to spend the same
coins twice
right and because you you have to have
this this trust in the middle this this
trust of the network the bitcoin network
to guarantee that you're sending me
coins that are real that you're not
going to send them to someone else at
all they get confirmed
and so the miners they produce these
these blocks and inside the blocks are
all these transactions there's a
mathematical problem they have to solve
to when they solve it they announce to
the network i've sold it and i've
included all of these transactions in my
block
so bitcoin mining is really transaction
confirmation so how are new bitcoins put
into circulation as soon as you find the
answer to one of these blocks as soon as
you put the traction in you then get to
claim 25 new coins
and you get to decide as to where those
coins go to
so we of course send them to ourselves
and send them to our customers so that
is the motivation for creating this
center if you imagine there's 3 600
coins released per day
the more computing power you have the
more of those 3 600 you have
if you have one computer in a tiny
facility you're not going to stand a
chance so you have this hyper growth of
this bitcoin network how secure is the
network the more computing power
building the chain the more secure the
chain is
if you wanted to take a transaction out
you would need approximately four
billion laptops today underneath your
control and you'd have approximately 10
minutes to do it
how many laptops do you have in your
facility
so laptops they don't work for us we
have very very specialist chips the
technology we have is the cutting edge
it's beyond the mobile phones it's we're
bleeding edge of the semiconductor
industry so the bitcoin is the most
secure network in the world
nobody has anything greater power than
what we have
the world's most secure network
can that be correct because
bitcoin system is
attack
so bitcoin is safer than the bank in
terms of computing power it is the
world's fastest growing payment network
how come such cutting-edge technology
has wound up in the swedish countryside
amongst them called bitcoin technology
and foreign
[Music]
silicon valley
it is actually thrown do you think
bitcoin is good for burden
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is that the conclusion of this
experiment
2
500 kilometers for a slice of cake and a
sorry no
no way
[Music]
maybe scandinavia is not ready for
bitcoin it's not easy to hand power and
control to a technology from an unknown
source but one thing is for sure
we have got a technology that can
revolutionize how we act together it is
up to us to use it to democratize the
economy and thus create a better society
that way we can all be satoshi nakamoto
[Music]
you